morning the el cortez hotel and casino  honored mayor carolyn goodman and her  husband former mayor oscar goodman they  unveiled their handprints in front of  the hotel dale cortez says the two  mayors have dedicated their lives to the  betterment of las vegas and the fremont  east entertainment district  owing them for their great work over two  decades  this is awesome really  it's awesome  what other city  has a plaque like this this is such a  wonderful thing for oscar and me to  enjoy to be together forever and ever  that's what you've just done here and  certainly nobody loves las vegas more  than we do  in fact mayor carolyn goodman told a  story at the presentation of how her  parents told her not to marry oscar that  they'd be divorced in a year  well the first couple of las vegas has  been married for more than 60 years so  congratulations to them